it's Tuesday September the 5th this show
is brought to you by manscape don't lie
you probably been using manscape ball
shaver on your face that's okay I do it
too so now it's time to pick up the
beard hedger it's a cordless trimmer
that gives you 20 different hair cutting
lengths all with one guard no more messy
drawers full of extra add-ons listen I
used the beard Eder I trimmed my armpits
with it it's [__] tremendous this
baby has a long lasting battery and a
strong motor that will get you the look
that you want if you're a clean shaving
kind of guy the handyman is your ticket
to a smooth stubble free look whether
you got a five o'clock shadow or you're
working on a wizard beard manscape has
the tools for you right now get 20% off
and free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com again 20% off and free
shipping at manscape.com use code Joey
hit the refresh button with
manscape turn off your TVs run for your
lives it's over they didn't put you on
this planet just to give up if Uncle joy
to do it I the rule the world actually
you got to be thinking welcome back
[Music]
to
what's up beautiful what's up buddy it's
good to see you thank you for calling
absolutely always we always chat one
night every night we chat for like an
hour 20 minutes we talk about comedy the
bets that Lee lost [__] like that so
we're just gonna get together now once a
week and do a church zoom and uh it's
going to be based on just uh current
events and sports since you guys know
we're just two fat bums that don't know
about nothing about nothing but we're
going to give you the best picks of the
year you understand me and it'll cost
you
zero I love back September 5th the
summer is over you can't dress in white
no more and uh Christmas is straight
ahead and if you're in debt I don't know
what to tell you you know what I'm
saying it's Tuesday it's over Jack so
let's open up the church you when you
usually go to Church they give you
communion like in the middle you know
they warm you up they got to kiss your
neck not tonight we're going in with the
Tom saguru capsules 200 milligram ABX
don't don't be showing up with a 50 that
LE you you gave it to me look at you
gave me this crazy jar and there's you
put a little nug of weed in there just a
tiny little one these are all these are
my
favorite me
too what's happening Brother
I'm thrilled I'm so happy to football
season I know you're excited about your
comedy career I want to congratulate you
and all the work you've been doing a lot
of people don't know that while you were
sitting in that room conning everybody
you were taking notes from the best from
Ralphie May to Theo Von to Tom sagur to
Rogan look at this you fooled the S [__]
suaga I just absorbed it I I always love
stand up and then I took a like I I
basically quit I thought in my head that
like the whatever like the cool things I
got to do with you like doing like I I
know you know but like the what I've
seen of the way Headliners have treated
me is something like I hope I can do but
that show that you Steve and I did at
the Wilbur I don't know what it was 2018
something like that 2019 20 whatever it
was I thought and it still could be I
thought it was the Pinnacle of my short
comedy career and when we came back I
was like you know [__] it I did what I
am going to do it's fun I'm never going
to be like a working stand up I thought
I thought it was a [__] crazy idea
and I I didn't do it for like a year and
a half I had a retirement show which is
[__] it was stupid and then one day my
mom called me and she was like listen I
think you're a little bit depressed cuz
my mom and my mom doesn't she would have
never thought I'd be doing standup but
she was like listen you've been a little
bit basically like to use your words
zbots like I've been I was just a little
bit not into it and I started up and
then I came to see you with Athena and
we went to uh comedy club in Jersey and
as you always do just surprised me and
said I was going up and I [__] bombed
and I freaked out but I was just I was
back and I've been back like really back
for a year and a half and I what you a
how many mics are you doing a week
now
I I try to do six to seven I can double
up I can double up Wednesdays and I can
double up uh maybe Thursday sometimes um
I've been really lucky Josh Wolf has
been like my savior he's been so cool to
me him and Jake we've gone on the road
um there's a couple clubs around here
there's one in chapi that I've I've been
doing a bunch it's been great there's a
club up in Saratoga New York that has
been really cool to me um it's really
cool like the I don't know if the word
Community right but like people it's
just nice the way Comics help each other
out you hear a lot of stuff on podcast
of Like Comics being shitty to each
other what you don't hear a lot of is
Like Comics are actually pretty [__]
cool to each other like our buddy
austino just got me uh a weekend in
Plano
Texas so I just did that last weekend
I've been doing a lot man it's it's been
because you know I heard you for years
talk about like the steps you take and
when I started I was just doing open
mics and then I would get little by
little and the past couple months I've
been busy I've been like one or two
weekends a month pretty much what I the
most is that you're you're doing dive
bars during the week oh yeah you know
people who are weird up front you walk
in there you're like what the [__] is
going on with my life but then on the
weekends you have a chance to go up in
front of real audiences with Josh Wolf
and that'll you know when I was at your
level three four years I was still in
Denver and I would just do you know
Mexican rooms with Jimmy a beta and I
would do you know anything I could do
for 25 bucks and then on the weekend I
would get get sets at the clubs it would
either be the George Mel's comedy club
or sometimes i' go to the comedy work
no not the Comedy Works the the place in
Colorado Springs they gave me five
minutes right you like in a month how
many Club spots would you have back then
do you
think would it be every weekend I wasn't
a clubber when I was in Denver I was an
open micer and then I was a uh I was
doing like wien wouldn't hire me because
I started there I was a door man there
they would give me any love and then you
had uh the comedy club that belonged to
George melie he put me up he gave me
guest spots and The Comedy Works would
have a tremendous headliner in the
weekend so there was nothing that was
Denver okay when I moved to
Seattle my whole game changed I went up
from uh you know yeah I still did a
couple one nighters I did bases army
bases but three or four nights I was at
the comedy under underground which at
the time was an A minus
room but you know there were people
going through there Louis CK Mark Marin
at the time there was a lot of guys that
you see today that are thriving that
went through there and that's where I
met them that's crazy like
it's do you remember because all I think
about right now like and it's it's just
though like I just I all the only word I
can use to describe it is like want like
I just have such a desire to be on the
road every weekend and I I look at these
things and it's just like I I don't I
it's like a magnet that I feel like it's
pulling me but I'm not anywhere close to
it I don't know how to describe it I was
dead and it's an addiction yeah it
really is like you get
so you know listen man to get anywhere
in comedy you have to be married to it
you know it was pretty funny I was
watching winning time with the Lakers
last week and he got offered magic got
off at 25 million for 25 years and he
was talking to the girl cookie that he
ended up marrying and he's like listen
man I'm married to the [__] Lakers
and if I'm married to the Lakers anybody
who wants to be with me has to be
married to the Lakers and I got to be
honest with you that's what happens you
are married to after three or four years
you get married to it and I look back at
my career now and I think about there
was a girl who hit me up about a year
and a half ago one night I hadn't spoken
to her in a long time she got my number
from a friend of mine in
Boulder and she was saying that she was
thinking about me that I was always
sweet when I was with her but she could
always tell I wasn't boyfriend material
and she goes it was a shame because I
really like you and we spoke for a
little while you know like I said I was
married to comedy at that time I was in
such a hole in my personal life that
standup was all I had and whether it was
a bombing or good set here's the it's
better than sitting on your
couch whether I bombed or had a good set
it was way better than staying home plus
I got a better chance of getting cocaine
if I went out ain't no cocaine in your
kitchen you know what I'm saying just
not going to fly under the pot so oh I
and and and the thing that like I the
way I feel now it's not that like I
don't want to spend time with my
girlfriend it's not like that you didn't
want it's not like you hated your
girlfriends but it's it's just there's
no even for five minutes like that feel
and I don't know about you because like
for you you're like you're you're a cal
person when we hang out but like you
know you're like an extra extrovert in a
way like kind of 5050 I'm a full-on
introvert but there's something about me
when I get on the stage I'm not yelling
I'm not I don't have like the stage
presence or whatever that you do but I
don't have the second thoughts or like
the doubt that I have in real life I
don't know what it is is I don't it
doesn't and I'll say say there was a
girl in Plano who just had her tits out
and everything front row and I would
have never even looked at her in real
life but I made a joke about tits and I
said not not as good as yours and like
the it was a good they they loved it but
like I would have never said that to her
in normal day life but there's something
about that I feel getting on stage that
for some reason I can say it you know
you be it becomes an altered e
you know it's crazy how my Alter Ego was
me in real life but when I went on stage
believe it or not the alter ego I had on
stage wouldn't say the [__] that I would
say in real life Wow you know soan you
talked about my Alter Ego I wouldn't
talk about abortion and I wouldn't talk
about [__] Nazi and Jews that was
never going to be coming out of my mouth
so for people who say they have all this
Freedom with standup I still had
personal beliefs that I didn't want to
talk about on stage and those were the
two of them and you you build around it
you know it's so weird the the journey
that is standup comedy whether you're
doing improv whether you're a writer
it's it's you need to get beat up a
little bit to realize your real
value and uh it's it's it could take a
long time or it could take a short
time it's really up to you what you want
to do with this and that's anything in
life that's anything you
know so I know I wanted to be a junkie
and I wanted to do comedy I didn't want
real life I didn't want to be
responsible I had a PO box and a pager
what does that tell you about somebody I
don't want nobody bothering me I'm on a
mission from Satan here you know and I
was doing triple runs and all these
things but looking back at it
now yeah I was married to
it do you regret
it yes and
no what what what parts do you
regret I regret that I forgot what a
life was like that's why people are in
Shock right now like you're not doing
standup because after the
pandemic I remembered what life was like
I never had a [__] life guys I
haven't had a life since
all right that's the truth that's the
honest to God truth I haven't had a home
you know
so
uh it's just really weird how things
[__] just work themselves out I
didn't have a home so for the first time
after the pandemic I came here and I was
like I enjoy watching TV with it I enjoy
doing all these things this after
tonight we're going to go see The
Equalizer her and I it's out already
yeah oh yeah it is out [__] yeah [__]
go see it so you know she's 10 but she
likes Man on Fire and this equalizer
whatever it's [__] called reunites
her and him oh she's in it yeah that
little girl's in it [__] yeah yeah no
Mexicans this time just straight up
blond and [__] I think Denzel's
killing Russians in this time you know
he ain't he ain't going after Mexicans
thank
god oh the Mexicans have hard had hard
enough oh that's so cool like yeah you
that's one it's been really cool like we
we went like I don't know maybe a year
without seeing each other and then I
come down now I come down like every 60
to 90 days what you and mercy have is
very very cool listen man I had a chance
at being a dad I blew it and I didn't
want to blow this one this meant more to
me than anything in the world so you
know listen she's already starting she's
going to be 11 in
January she's already got girlfriend's
coming over and you know today I took
her to lunch she had a white skirt on
with a green blouse you know I thought
she was going to play [__] tennis I
thought she was going to the US Open or
some [__] and the truth of the matter is
she's getting older and yeah she still
hang together but in time she's going to
be a part I'll force her to do little
things you know I drive her to
MMA I drive her to a few things you know
tomorrow I got to go uh clothes shopping
with her you know I take it a couple
different stores and my wife takes it to
the more personal stuff I'm enjoying it
do I miss anything not at all I do not
miss being involved in a strike which
we'll get
to because I'm sure a lot of people want
to see what our views on on the
strike and uh the no bail [__] in La
like I'm very happy down here I don't go
up north a lot I don't go up to the city
at all basically Ally you know I have a
life down here my job is a podcast now
I'm going to start rewriting a book I'm
gonna start writing a book on comedy on
the journey on the on the psychology of
it you know when you see a
pitcher it's a pitcher but then you go
see Roger Clemens Pitch live and it
wasn't that his pitching was so good as
his psychology of the
game and I think what do you mean by
that
he would [__] terrorize batters with
intimidation his body language he never
smiled on the
mound it was all a psychological attack
on the batter after he would throw the
ball he would walk towards the batter to
try to [__] with him and while he walked
back he would keep his eye on the batter
it was it was mental Warfare and you
think that got in their heads you bet
your [__] ass he didn't win the Sai
Young Award because you know and this I
I've watched how people have used a
certain it's not psychology I've watched
how people have
stoken stuck to a code and
they flourish that way I.E Led Zeppelin
his manager did something that nobody
ever did before he would get paid up
front for the shows he would let them be
do any TV shows no uh [__] Midnight
Special none of that stuff he had a code
he had a certain code and with standup
that it's not even a code it's just it
would be good for the open micer to
understand these things about standup
you know later and I don't want to get
into them right now you know but uh what
do you think about this [__] strike
because people people hit me up every
day and and they ask what the strikers
blah blah blah blah and I'll be honest
with you it's about [__] doe right
somebody don't like somebody's do is in
somebody else's [__]
pocket uh I mean it's going on whatever
four months for the writer strike and
two for the [__] actor strike maybe
yeah two two
months and I gotta be honest with you
and I know I'm gonna get a lot of
backlash for this and people going to
bust my
balls I'm really concerned about the
little businesses
you know we lived in Burbank you know we
lived close to Burbank I mean we
were twice a [__] month you know and
even if I live here I still became a
connected to that area and especially in
Burbank I think about tacos
1776 that's where that people were going
to eat all day from the studios I think
about that dry cleaner that's open 24
hours what who do you who takes clothes
to a dry cleaner at 3: in the morning a
Coke fiend and actors you know like a
like a studio you know the next day to
prepare I like that place they had Oreos
for free they what they had Oreos for
free that store I used to go in there
and just steal an
Oreo Jesus Christ we who steals a
[__] Oreo you have to have some
decency at some point
but uh that's who I Think About You Know
listen again I'm going to get some
backlash for this or somebody will be
mad at me for saying this
but I've seen some of those writers on
Facebook and I know a lot of them and uh
a lot of them are hurting but a lot of
them have trust funds or they're like
everybody else in Hollywood they're
living off credit cards and they figured
out a way to do it and
uh so my concern is that those small
businesses I mean they just recovered
from [__]
coid they just started making a profit
from [__] you know so that's who I
think about the little people the above
the below the line people you know uh
I'm I'm always very honest on podcast I
saw something that Disturbed me in the
beginning they said the average sag
actor makes 65,000 a year I lived in
that life for 23 years I've been a
member of the union for a little more
than that and I gotta be honest with you
guys I only made over 60,000 three
years right the rest of the years I was
at 20,000 30,000 and I had a book a
commercial for that you know just to
give the people at home an example when
I got to Hollywood a guest star was
anywhere from 20 to 25 G's a week now a
guest star is seven [__]
thousand you know so over the years and
listen Co banged out the budget you know
let me tell you what happened with Co
they had to have a budget for Co but
CO's gone now and they're still singing
the co budget so somebody's taking this
[__] money okay and I've done you
know I paid my dues I did a lot of $100
a day
movies and you know you have to pay for
your own dry cleaning I mean one
question comes to mind and I got I want
you guys to know this I had to pay for
my own plane ticket to do a dairo
Stallone movie now at the time I was
under the ether and I really wanted to
do the rooll and and I had free points
and [__] you know I got like a free
ticket out of it and they put me up in
the Hotel because I had a Houston
address you
know but think about
that I did a heavy million doll budget
and I had to pay for my own
[__] plane ticket you know
again I'm not crying but think about
that well I think the $660,000 thing is
skewed because of like Will Smith making
$20 million at movie so like now they
came back and they spoke about how
actors barely make insurance you know
during the pandemic The Screen Actors
Guild decided to pull away residuals
from Counting towards your insurance
that kills a guy like me right what
percentage time what like after like 20
years what percentage of your income was
residuals do you
think right now listen I shot one movie
this year in an episode of Law and
Order I don't want to divulge what I got
for the movie I don't want to divulge
what I got for Law and Order but I'm not
driving a Mercedes Benz you know what
I'm saying so right I'm still EA piz
like a [__] Freehold so D you
you could win the lottery and still be
eating crispy pizza yeah no no but you
know what I'm saying I I don't have a
buler I don't have a personal chef
nothing like that and uh like this year
I got insurance this year I lucked out
because I shot a film in June so I got
insurance and now they extended it for
three months for the strike so that
means I get insurance now till [__]
San Janeiro day nice I'm still waiting
on residuals from Law and Order
hopefully I'll get some residuals from
this movie I don't have to tell you that
my longest yard is on every night
guys I'll always eat chines food because
the longest yard is on every night are
my residuals big every once in a while
but guess what [__] you'll see it
this week on CBS at 8 o'clock and that's
a nice for Uncle Joey okay switch to the
channel if you know what's on what's
that do you switch to the channel if you
know it's on just so like the viewership
goes up I would do that no no no no I I
don't listen if I I I saw that movie
when it came out and then I didn't watch
it again for years and when it would
come on TV I would put it on for like a
second and it wasn't until about three
years ago that I rewatched it and I was
like Jesus [__] Christ you know it's
going to
be uh the 25 year anniversary or the 20
year anniversary is in two years but
next year is the 20th year that we Shot
the movie that was 20 [__] years ago
and they still play the [__] movie
every goddamn [__] night so I'm
really happy about that and I you know I
hope that the strike doesn't break the
union you know the writers the m wmp
whatever the [__] it is made a statement
that they were going to break the
writers they were going to make them
sell their homes and [__] that's a cold
blooded [__] statement yeah
that's the way like I look at it and I
was never part of a union but before I
met you I moved to LA to be an editor
and I got to work on some pretty cool
reality shows but I also interviewed for
a lot of shitty and I worked for a
couple shitty ones and they would hit
you up and it's non-un like there's one
[__] them there's one that you watch
poker on ESPN I won't say the name name
of the show it's a big show you see it
all all the time they wanted to pay 900
a week which is not just for a reference
back this was 15 years ago I was already
making 1,200 a week and and for a union
you're making two grand a week but they
do that because you don't work all the
time you have to take months off and the
thing that bugged me was there's always
going to be people who just because
they're oh
[__] it's that time [__] I wish I had
some but there's always going to be
people who take jobs that are too low
paying and I feel bad for like the the
restaurant people too but I also I feel
bad for the people who are moving to
LA and like I don't I'm me not that I
don't care about like the will Smiths
and Tom Cruz but they're going to be
fine this is for the people who are
making 10 grand a year like that that's
what I think it's for and I think I
don't like how
the studios and the production companies
all they care about and I get it they're
a business they got to make whatever
they got to
make but they they're not honest about
it they make it seem like they don't
have it they have it it's like they have
the money it's they just don't want they
want their profits to be whatever they
want so I definitely I don't love it I'm
happy that for like podcasters and for
other people that maybe they can grow
during this time but no I don't I I the
the way that like
corporations are are are trying to [__]
with us I don't like at
all I've said a thousand times we're
living in a time
that this is
unacceptable As Americans this is
unacceptable you know what I'm saying
but you know
what who gives a Frenchman's [__]
Thursday night it's the Kansas City
Chiefs against the Detroit Pistons
against the Detroit Lions let me tell
you that's be a good game and I know you
guys are going to look at me and go
you're such a [__] hypocrite no again
when Lee and I used to do the podcast
and Lee would tell me he'd watch
football on Sunday that and then he' go
you know we might be shut the [__] up
Lee you're not part of the Miami you're
not part of the [__] New England yes
I am look stop it
so you know I used to say Le you watch
because for 30 [__] years I didn't
watch football I would have watch a game
here a game there you know I wouldn't
watch football I was in a hotel room
writing [__] jokes and I knew if I
watched football I wouldn't write no
[__] jokes I moved here three years
ago once I move into the house Jimmy
Florentine invites me to his house on a
Sunday
football and I was blown the [__] away
by the the two TVs the food the the
[__] [__] that comes out of their
mouth I didn't think they had guys like
that anymore he's got two guys the
Jewish guy and my other buddy who goes
over there they [__] these guys go
off on everything the announcers the
cheerleaders everybody Burns in hell
with these [__] Savages and I just
started watching football again on
Sunday not 10 hours
work I'll do something on Sunday with
the family and then I'll go to Jimmy's
at halftime in the Miami Dolphin game
watch Miami Dolphin because they're a
Miami Dolphin Family the Florentine
crime family I watch the beginning of
another game then I come home and then
maybe if the game the seven o'clock game
is interesting I'll put that on at night
but it's not like I've been watching 10
hours a day I don't have the NFL package
even though I'm thinking of getting it
this year ah I love it I've gotten into
baseball again you know that's the one
that's hard for me I like basketball
again I paid attention to basketball I
started playing attention so I I don't
know what the future brings you know
what I'm saying I'm just knowing I'm
having a good time raising a [__]
child and I put my bets in from time to
time with the [__] best
DraftKings so now for a word from our
sponsors yo football season is back and
draftking sports book the official
sports betting part of the NFL is here
with a tremendous new offer they've done
it again new customers but
on any pro football team and score 200
bonus bets instantly that's right $5 on
any NFL game this week and score 200 and
bonus bets you never know what's going
to happen tackle a bite to the neck the
only thing you could definitely count on
is the incredible offers from DraftKings
life's more fun when you're in on the
action download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and use code Joey new
custom score 200 in bonus bets when you
bet $5 on any NFL football game only at
DraftKings with code Joey Jo OE y you
got a gambling problem call 1800 Gambler
or
www.1 1800 gambler. net let's get this
party started all right bonus bets
expire 7 days after the Ed eligibility
and deposit restrictions apply live
download the draftking Sportsbook app
use code Joey all right we're back you
Savages over here chitchatting about the
usual [__] now we got to talk about who
you like this weekend Lee I know you've
looked first of all Lee calls me this
morning he goes so we do a segment on
who's gonna win the Super Bowl I go Lee
you're gonna have a hard time picking
[__] Thursday all right why worry
about the Super Bowl you know [__]
Henry Houdini so knock it the hell off
you know but now I agree with Lee maybe
we should make a Super Bowl
prediction magic screen here there's
what I actually DraftKings I look today
it's on your [__] phone okay and you
can look at the odds to see at any time
the other thing I like about DraftKings
if you're sucking at baseball football
voila hit the [__] Casino me with
this DraftKings [__] Casino I love
the [__] thing but anyway jealous
they they need to get it in
Massachusetts they still don't have it
in Massachusetts I have DraftKings but I
can't do the
casino all right here you go add plus
200 to any team's odds to win told you
2024 superball
so Boom come on give it to me [__]
where is it all right they got a bunch
you got the Kansas City
Chiefs Jesus Christ
the Chiefs are plus 600 the Eagles are
plus
650 they got the bills at plus
900 and they you know
what I like the bang I like the Bengals
and this is where like I get greedy like
this is why I always lose bets is
because I love boost like that because
they have the Bengals at plus 1100 right
now and if you put at the bonus they'll
be plus
1300 all that one the top 10 teams
Kansas City Chiefs Buffalo Bills
Cincinnati Bengals the Jets Detroit
Philly San Francisco Dallas Baltimore
and the Miami Dolphins who do you see
taking the Super Bowl this year Tarzan
do you think Kansas City could do it
again do you think this is the year
that's Savage over at
Cincinnati I'm leaning towards
Cincinnati or Philadelphia what's that
brother you I I don't think Baltimore I
like Baltimore Baltimore's always [__]
with us the Patriots but I like Philly
or Cincinnati I don't like Philly was so
close last year I like Philly a lot they
it pisses me off because they beat they
beat the Patriots in the Super Bowl I
like I really like Joe B I was gonna ask
you that you used to call me when Tom
Brady was on the Patriots and be like
that's like what like white like you
said you like you love Tom Brady almost
as much as I did but like now like is
there a quarterback that you like now I
like the kid from uh Cincinnati you know
you gota love the guy from right now if
you bet the Detroit tigers lions 25
bucks you win
$575 okay yeah uh what were you saying
my brother look at look Philadelphia
Eagles has a great quarterback but he's
been very busy during the off season
like he's doing commercials and you know
his you know everything went up a little
bit and sometimes those guys lose a
little bit of focus so I still love
Philadelphia don't get me wrong if
anybody could [__] steamroll this
league it's Philadelphia you understand
me uh Kansas City they always they
always show up one way or another
Buffalo I don't know I I love buffalo
but I think they had a a bad break last
season I think they had good
momentum so yeah you were saying that
the Philadelphia you love
Philadelphia love Philadelphia I love
Philadelphia but you know uh he got a
lot of publicity this year I saw him
last week during the Philly whatever
preseason game he had the earrings on
you know he looks like he's been using
manscape on his face and uh yeah and I
love the guy but I'm looking at that
also there's a lot of things you could
look at right now how do you like what
do you think about the Lions because I
and it's hard for me think the lions are
tough the Lions show a lot that's why
push the Lions because if you're going
to bet $25 and win 575 the Lions
wouldn't be that bad if you bet Kansas
City right now and you bet 25 you get
$77 or something hold on you got
$177 what my [__] glasses godamn
[Music]
it
anyway we're back here if I bet 25 bucks
on Kansas City Chiefs I go for
175 if I bet look at this bet here $25
on the Miami Dolphins I get
650 the Miami Dolphins if Tua stays
healthy they've got a tremendous
offensive [__]
Juggernaut and uh they could be
somewhere but two
is I like them the kids got [__]
heart he got bounced those his head
couple times last you know the the
[__] protocols and all this [__] in
the old days they put that [__]
back in they give him a little [__]
smell ins salt you get like Sally's
panties and put under his nose and he
comes right out of it and boom we're
back like [__] herpes that [__] is
strong dude Josh Potter brings that on
the road with him he doesn't do like red
bulls or stuff he does smelling salts
that stuff is strong but I like I like
Goff like that the quarterback for the
Lions like I just like like they like La
threw him to the side I like the coach
of the Lions I don't know what it is and
it's hard for me I can't root for
another team but I don't think the
Patriots have a a shot in hell and you
never know let's talk about the Patriots
Sunday they're going up against
Philadelphia at home and they're
retiring [__] Brady shirt so you look
at a game like that and you're like
Philadelphia is going to
steamroll yeah think so God knows if
somebody puts a leprechaun up [__]
Tom Brady's ass and New England wins 44
to nothing what's that gonna look like
that's why I'll stay away from that game
right now the only game I'm thinking
about for Sunday early game is I like
the
Jaguars I like the Jag who are they
playing they're minus five against the
Indianapolis
Colts on Thursday night I'm going with
nobody yet but let me put it to this way
Kansas City playing at home it's the
season opener Thursday night you know
you never seen a bookie with a [__]
part-time job all right I mean it can't
be that simple they given six and a
half what can you see I don't know what
the over and under is for which one for
Kansas City Detroit on Thursday night
this Thursday 53 and a half right now
okay there you have it so you know those
games those specialty games usually go
if on a regular day I could see [__]
you know uh Detroit scored some points
and I don't have to tell you what Kansas
City could do so 53 looks like a [__]
fart in cup it ain't no big deal but at
the same time I don't know who what if
[__] Detroit comes out and puts on 26
points and they scored three and you got
29 the [__] total so there's so many
crazy things that could happen I will
not look at Thursday till
Thursday this week right now going into
Sunday I love [__] uh the Jaguars
with my that little blond dude that can
throw the ball and you'll do the you'll
do the line yeah Indies Five Five Points
minus five and then Monday night you got
a great game uh again this is a
Sentimental game you got 911 New York
City Aaron roders starting at the giant
Stadium against uh the [__] Buffalo
Bills you know I I mean who could pick
this one so I see this one the over
under is lower though huh it's 46 yes
that's why I like this with the over on
this but right now I like the over let's
see what happens over the weekend but
that's who I would go with listen it's I
told you [__] for years if
you're gonna put some bets in it's like
the crucifixion right Thursday they put
One Nail in your [__] head Friday you
think you're going to win back some
money so you back College basketball
whatever they put another nail in your
coffin so now you're hanging up with one
nail and then come Saturday you're
[__] bet again now you got two Nails
in your hand then Sunday you lose the
first game that's a nail in your foot
afternoon game that's nail in the other
foot and then you lose the Sunday game
that's just a chisel to your [__]
head and now you better pray for [__]
barabus to get you out of a pinch for
Monday night so you can win back if not
you got to pay that book on Thursday or
in today's uh FanDuel DraftKings all
these Casino things you know they take
it right out of here which I appreciate
these because I don't got to see no guy
in a diner on Thursday right my little
$25 bet and I know where I
stand now I have a I have a few
questions hit me it would you do you
usually bet early season because to me
like anyone who I like I can't imagine
betting preseason but even like the
first week bet preseason you got a
monkey on your back I can see you at
Young asight betting a [__] horse or
something all right but uh first season
listen Baltimore's giv 10 point 12
points to
Houston that's a lot of [__] wood on
paper I could see Houston uh you know
Baltimore beating him by [__] 80
points but 12 points on open and watch
I'm gonna bite my tongue I guarantee
[__] Baltimore beats him I wouldn't
do it the first week right I wonder if
like unders are more popular like like
at the beginning not not popular but
like if you see a lot of unders in in
the season in the preseason cuz like or
in the first couple weeks problem with
football is listen they're gonna kill
you one way or another it's like Blondie
you know what I'm saying Blondie's gonna
get you one way or another so football's
gonna get you one way or another it's up
to you how long you want to get in there
you know everybody talks about a bank
roll this and this well now it's your
ATM card right you put your ATM card
there and you [__] they they bang you
out so you're not going to go into Big
Time debt you steal Grandma's ATM card
which I can see a lot of Knuckleheads
doing that [__] but you know this when I
was a kid I did I [__] up with
gambling so much I I didn't do it again
and then I went to work for a sports
betting service and I sat behind the
lines and I saw the mentality of it and
you start to understand the Gambler and
that's the last thing I want to do I
don't want to become a gambler but I
don't mind putting 25 bucks in the game
to make it more exciting
I love it I love it you know what I like
about draftking they have the [__]
quick
gsps the same game parlays yeah all
right those things are [__] tits
because you could bet 10 bucks on one of
those things like right now like the you
know one of the football ones I saw was
check this out they have and you could
bet this tonight they
have uh what the [__] is it like uh the
guy from Miami to leave the league in
scoring whatever his name is Malik I
don't
know uh Tyreek Hill to lead the league
in receiving yards it's nine it's
betting plus 900 right you throw $10 on
that you throw a 20 on that you win 200
bucks you bet that's crazy if you throw
a a $10 bill on it you win a 100 bucks
for 10 bucks to watch it kicking off
with
Kelsey Travis Kelce to score first
touchdown plus
500 right so like but do you how many
bets will you put in in a week like what
do you think it's smart like if you're
just having fun that's something
different but if you're trying to
actually win do you do like one bat two
what like what do you normally do I go
with what I
like okay I go what I like if I wake up
one morning morning and I'm like I look
at first for me it starts with Yahoo I
click on the Yahoo and I see the
matchups you're the only person that
still goes to Yahoo you know me I'm an
old school [__] I still got hot
mail what we what are we getting out
here you know what I'm
saying and then we take it from there
and then if I see something that looks
interesting I'll see what time it's at
and I'll see who's uh who's pitching
who's who's you know and usually in
baseball you got to give a a run and a
half but you start to know teams like
this year my biggest thing I had was
Cincinnati Cincinnati either loses
outright or they're going to beat you by
one run on a money line they're G to
come from behind they're very exciting
they're having a great time when they
play baseball you don't see that much I
mean they got beat up by [__] they're
on a West Coast trip now they got beat
up by San Diego I don't know who they're
playing tonight I have no [__] idea
but like today was a great day to gamble
because you had four baseball games and
it was the beginning of college football
and DraftKings was giving you 50% profit
boost for baseball so you put 20 bucks
on somebody you're collecting you know
58 at least I'm doubling my money I'm
not going to put $25 to win [__] 42
I'm not taking that sweat I got to
double it even if it's $62 I double it
you know that's how I look at things I'm
not looking to become a millionaire I'm
just looking to have some fun fun if I'm
bored one day I look at the thing boom B
beep and you [__] uh there you are
like Johnny bamboo it doesn't matter if
I bet five or a 100 baseball gives me so
much an like if I if I bet baseball as
much as I'm going to bet football I
would die of a heart attack because
baseball takes so goddamn long that I
can't it gives me anxiety to watch it I
don't know how you bet that but first
off you know I don't
it's not like I do it a lot I don't have
the baseball package so I can't really
watch the game so if I can't watch the
game I can't really cheer for them you
know what I'm saying next year I'll I'll
watch the series and you can't listen
baseball will kill you because it's
every day yeah it's every day so don't
even think about it if you look at
something one day and it looks good to
you B for me it was Baltimore this year
Tampa
Bay I mean you bet the Yankees it's like
giving away money to charity might you
can't figure them out finally they beat
Detroit yesterday with Derek Cole Garett
Cole on the mound or whatever uh yeah
baseball is gonna suck you dry it's like
basketball it's every day [__] listen
you get me a guy with a turban who reads
[__] minds he's not gonna bust out
[__] seven winners a week okay that's
why when you see a psychic sign go in
there [__] with him listen give me the
next on the track they're all stumbled
they could tell you about a a great
nephew that's looking for you in the
spirit world but you can't tell me the
[__] winner of the game this after
give me a break all right if you're a
psychic you're throwing Heat at me yeah
why why has no one even I've never even
heard that why is no psychic doing
sports because it's listen Michael
Jordan couldn't win and he played the
game AR sster couldn't win and he played
the game you had about five or six
athletes that were legitimate [__]
gamblers and listen come on who doesn't
bet on themselves
or teams that you know what they're
about so if they can't beat it who the
[__] are you to think well I got a
system yeah your system is a [__]
loan from Grandma in about a year when
you're [__] you know selling blood at
Clinic did you see that like that
article like Phil Michelson bet like a
billion dollars I think he said it was
[__] but I believe it yeah these
guys are you know listen when you have
that I am not a degenerate but I've seen
degenerate gamblers and number one
degener Gambler I saw was my mother the
horses and baseball that's the recipe
for [__] death right there you know
so and like it's hard to say because she
like just the idea of a phone would have
[__] her up but like what do you think
like some like that like being able to
bet from your house without having to go
anywhere what like what would what would
your mom have thought about that well
listen it's not like I could go on the
computer and just make the BET and tell
him I'm going to pay him on Thursday
to's World okay today's world's a little
different I mean you have people
gambling look what New York made the
first three months of gambling it's
unreal because people are gambling now
that were never gambling before never
they started during the pandemic because
they were bored whether it was playing
cards with a live dealer you know
playing car whatever it's entertainment
guys it's entertainment yeah if you're a
poker guy
you might make it to the finals you know
I don't know how that works I don't like
cards I don't know anything about cards
every once in a while go on casino
Blackjack Casino I play like 50 cents
Blackjack I get my ass kicked I don't
know what I'm doing I'm not holding I'm
not calling I even tried to play the
dice the computer almost [__] blew up
you know I don't know much about I
didn't I didn't grow up playing cards of
dice you know I love to tell you that
yeah I played in an alley that wasn't me
so but uh yeah it's just
responsibly it's like drinking it's like
doing coke you do Coke one night a week
you're Li your nut sack on fire you jump
up and down when you do it six nights a
week it's gonna end bad you know what
I'm saying anything you do six nights a
week is gonna [__] end bad you could
drink Vodka every night oh well nobody
will smell it well but wa till you start
pissing blood then you'll smell it blood
mixed with alcohol I know a couple
Russians that smell like that Bloody
vodka you ever smell them it's like a
[__] smell like a like a [__]
Bloody Mary but without the celery
stick anyway I'm just imagining a an
ball sack getting L on fire so yeah
that's where you're at this weekend and
I listen you wait all year for this
there's people that wait all [__]
year for this time of the year I love
football hummus goes up 20% not in my
household it's [__] onion dip I want
sour cream
farts like do you have anything like
because like like you said we're both
fat [__] like that's I I don't do it
anymore but my favorite thing to do when
I lived in LA with you on Sundays was to
get a pizza and wings and chips and cold
soda and I just sit there and like I
literally could have like my skin could
have grafted to the couch I love there's
nothing I love more than Pizza and Wing
like what would you get on if you were
gonna go to town on football if I was
gonna go to town on football I get some
[__] fried rice from uh what's his
name PE King steady mty over at Kings
get a couple [__] on order spare ribs
yeah but I won't do
that I don't do that because I don't
like eating in my [__] I don't like
eating downstairs I'm in this
[__] I don't want them in here
I'm down to one cat so I have friends in
this area that have little mice in the
winter I see a mice I this [__] house
I I light this [__] on fire I
see a m so really yeah I don't like m
no one likes mice but what like what
would you do I just told you I would
light the [__] house on fire I don't
like goddamn mice a Scarface didn't like
Colombians I don't like mice you know
what I'm saying I don't like mice and
flies I was down the out of banks last
week and I took some mushrooms like I
did tonight and I'm sitting there
getting Sun listening to music Madonna
I'm listening to [__] Michael Shanker
but the whole time I'm just killing
flies they're landing on my thigh and I
would smack them take the wing off and
put them between my legs by the time I
finished on the mushrooms there was like
11 flies buzzing around so they were
still alive so I put them in the [__]
jar with one inch of water and I put
them outside the sun beamed on them all
day I came back two days later they were
complete different color you know what
I'm saying they had that disease Michael
Jackson had it was that skin got all
light what's it called a monilia Migo
bigo yeah it looks like they had bigo
and [__] the stuff you do to flies dude
is out of you why do you put water in
there I don't like [__] I don't like
I don't like mice okay I don't like rats
I'll take a snake you got a snake send
them over you got a cat yeah you got a
raccoon a baby raccoon I'll raise that
[__] a skunk be scented I'm in
I'll put them in the back of my hat and
go out with
people I don't like M either but that's
what people should get a [__] skunk
for self-defense a lot of people don't
know how to handle that if I'm going to
mug you and I see a skunk behind you
I'll [__] my pants I'll stab myself I
don't want to get hit with I gotta go
lay tomato juice I don't have a dime
what do you think I'm robbing you
for like a a guard skunk could you train
a skunk to do that yeah I had a friend
and well he was a counselor a camp
counselor at Five-Star Basketball
Camp sorry about the thing I think I
have a walk in Pony I'll find out next
Wednesday uh he had a skunk Kenny dinard
from duke had a skunk had a
and he had carry it in his in his uh
hood on his
sweatshirt and the you rather do that
than have a mouse one time yeah because
they desent them they take the scent out
and they can't spray you then you go to
[__] in a sporting good store where they
have hunting material and you could buy
the scent in a little jar and you put
that outside your mother's door one
night and [__] with a little bit you
know what I'm
saying she got T in the middle night
there skunking
man I swear this a skunk yeah have you
done that that seems like a trick you
would do is just walk around with the
scent and leave it people's houses no I
went to a sporting good one time levies
in West New York New Jersey and the guy
had it there and I bought a little thing
and I don't know I'm not gonna tell you
the whole story because it's not good
but I whipped it at somebody they must
have taken yeah I didn't know the person
you know it was during a transaction one
of those you know I got a gun
huh that CVS a transaction yeah it was
like a little transaction you give me a
little CVS card by the
way by no way is this a promotion I love
CVS to [__] you sign up for that
package they have you love this package
yes like $12 a year and you get like
coupons for everything that you need
like when I get coupons it's for like
fungi toenail
powder
[__] mcor gum you know [__]
sunglasses you know [__] like that that
was like when we met you you told me
like listen I want to send YouTube $5
they've been doing like I I can't
imagine you liking the deal at CVS I do
I take the deal it's a tremendous I'm an
old man guy I'm not 28 no more I'm not
38 I'm not 48 I'm not 58 I'm gonna
attend the golden age of 60 years old as
a matter of fact I got a $2 discount on
my movie ticket you understand me [__]
that's how I'm pimping it now and I
resigned up with T-Mobile because I
haven't been to Sprint in like 10 years
so I went back I have T-Mobile now you
know T-Mobile became Sprint I gonna say
I think you have I think you have Sprint
they cut my bill in half [__] because
I'm over
55 wow come on I added another line I
got another number now I could maneuver
with you know what I'm saying like being
60 now do I like being 60 what are my
options it's not like you cannot like it
what do you want me to do
[__] put on nice shoes and go out and
hang out at the bar with young people
and make believe I'm
[__] after a while you know that's my
biggest fear is smelling like an old man
you ever smell an old man when you were
a kid yeah you're like God damn that's
why I don't want to smell like an old
man I take showers I wash my feet I
[__] buff them out now because I
don't want to smell like an old man so I
don't want to get stop putting the weed
in the same jar with the foot stuff oh
no I do put it in the same container
when I got back from North Carolina I
buffed out my toenail had a little sand
in there it's ready for you I got that
[__] uh that toenail dust to put the
next blunt forget about it it's like
smoking mushroom too and that's why I
tell Lee my toenails are like a mushroom
like if you take some like if I put some
of that toenail Dust In Your Water
you're seeing [__] Chinese people an
hour later you hear [__] seeing
swords and flying [__] stars
and see look you say these things like
it's a
positive like why would I positive it's
not a positive I don't want to see
Chinese people listen it's always good
to have Chinese people around they show
up with spare ribs no I like it when
they're just around like normally I
don't want to see like I can go for some
Freddy makes the best pork fried rice
with extra egg and Sprouts you've ever
had your [__] life a bowl of won soup
and I'm ready for [__] War you
understand me I don't anre
I go for Crown Palace for my Entre the
shrimp and lobster sauce will put hair
on your nut sack even if you got
sarcopenia down there whatever the [__]
the misso there's no s I don't think you
got one letter right
sopena oh my
God but like you changed my life at
Freddy's because I never I
love Banton soup and I love Hot Mustard
I've never put it in the soup before
that is which no I said that come on
that's Jewish type stuff that's what I
like about study Freddy's you're
surrounded by Jews they know what time
it is bro they got that the word
surrounded is an interesting choice
what's that the word like surrounded
sounds like it's
dangerous n surrounded by Jews listen if
you're surrounded by ISIS that's
dangerous being surrounded by Jews
you're in [__] Heaven one's a dentist
one's a lawyer one guy has a sneaker
shop you know you can't [__] lose
here
surrounded by juice that [__] edible
kind of hit me but the mushroom hit me a
little more I'm ready for [__] War I
like these this is uh this is the
laughing assas I don't know what it is
Rainbow ruts it's strawberries with
Skittles in it is that the white one no
that's the pink one the strawberry one
why would it be got it okay it's pink
that's white truffle and then the one is
really good it's like caramel like a
chocolate [__] tremendous and then
the other one is like a crispy chocolate
and I like that too I like siles brand
too I had some siles when I was down in
North Carolina I ate the [__]
strawberry and cream I went to I was the
referee of a kid's uh flag football
thing right because I couldn't run
because my knee in the dirt yeah oh was
that at a school like it was like an
invent or was just your family took down
there okay I was like how you just end
up the referee steveen Nuno were the
quarter backs and I was the referee I
had a one of the kids I had to find him
15 yards for Unnecessary Roughness I had
a whistle you know what I'm saying I was
[__] but I took mushrooms before I
went I usually take mushrooms and stay
home and mind my [__] business I
don't want to bump into nobody in
mushrooms yeah so I [__] went over to
the field and next thing you know I was
watching the grass moving I'm like this
is no
bueno and did you run around as the ref
like you were running around on
mushrooms no I can't run around because
I have that [__] cough and I think I
got you know the [__] uh but you were
raing on mushrooms huh you were raing on
on that silly bar yeah what do you think
you're dealing with joy bananas I just
told you that didn't I [__] sucker but
that's that's crazy I can't imagine like
what like I freak out like I would freak
out being around kids at that age did
you throw a flag at Mercy no mercy
caught one of the balls you she did okay
she was not you know she wasn't the kids
just the one kid picked them up and
threw them down it was you know momentum
you know what I'm saying so okay you let
it
slide game [__] what do
you okay let me pull it up I like
um
Dam I I I I want to say that Patriots
but I don't think I
can I like you know what I really like
Detroit and I'm trying to like see I go
for I try to go for like kind of not
upsets but like I don't like winning
like you said like five
bucks I
think I think the the Jets might win the
Jets are a slight Underdog right now
over Buffalo I think they want I think I
think they want him to win I like I
think Buffalo is a better team but then
I don't know what's going on I heard
whatever their star uh wide receiver is
like he wants to leave digs like now he
wants to leave but see like I whatever I
say you can just bet against me because
I'm I'm I'm going to lose I don't I want
you to be organized I want you to look
at Thursday's game first if you like
Thursday's game then you touch it if you
don't like it you stay the [__] away
from it you watch it at halftime till
the end of the game and then you look at
Saturday but there's also college
football on Saturday this week so
there's College on Friday there was
College on well last week I'm talking
about so this week you have college
football if you think there's something
in college football you like then you go
if not you wait for [__] Sunday and
then I don't know [__] about college
football game let's start with the first
game on Sunday the the one o'clock game
and then you see how you do and you see
how the day is going if there's a bunch
of upsets and [__] like that now you
know so now you going to the four
o'clock with different thoughts that's
why I don't like giving out a bunch of
picks I like giving out the the game I
like for Sunday the main game is the
Jaguars and then uh you know I don't
know what the Sunday night game is yet
and I have no [__] I know Monday's
September 11th and they're playing at
Giant
stadium and it's the home opener of
Aaron roders which people got them
winning the Super Bowl for a certain uh
whatever I got no opinion on it you know
let's see I think he's a little older
and I think he's going to get chased
around there but Tom Brady [__] mad
to do it so uh look at that game 1:00
then go to the four then go to the seven
if there's nothing there but you're
waiting for Monday night then you bet
you bet Monday night a little heavier if
you were G to bet 25 on Thursday and 25
on Sunday and you didn't touch it now
you got 75 for [__] Monday night so
you can bet yourself a little parlay
with three legs you know how many
touchdowns is Aaron Rogers going to have
bet the Jets or or the side and then
over and you got a three-way [__]
parlay how's that for you a three- leg
parlay that's you know and whatever site
you're on they'll take care of you I
prefer DraftKings I've been working for
them I've been with them for five years
one is a consumer or four years one as a
consumer and then I reached out to them
and because I like what they do so
that's Uncle Joey you know what I'm
saying I love it I and but I don't I
guess I'll pick I'll pick one game of
the week and I'm gonna pick
the I think I like that one the bills
and the and the and the Jets and I think
I and I I don't know if it's [__]
rigged I don't want to say that and
that's Monday I guess I don't know if
it's rigged but I think the storylines I
think they want Aaron Rogers to win that
game and I it's nothing it's just it's
the same thing with the strike the Stars
win that's I just
I you got any dates this weekend you got
any dates coming up this week we this
weekend I don't have any dates um my
next big one I have a show in Worcester
on the 16th at Pepe's takaria or Pepe's
Dolce bar that's the big one and then uh
the fun one at the end of the month
September 28th through the 30th I'm at
the Omaha funny bone with Josh Wolf
that's a good [__] club you're gonna
have I'm really excited about that one
and I get to do a longer set because
unfortunately Jake's not coming this
that week but it's going to be it's
going to be Josh and myself and I'm
really so excited we'll talk about
September 28th then even SE September
5th we're 23 days away I want you to
give me what's coming up next this
weekend you're a [__] that's all I got
and looking for the people at home I
started doing the book
signings and um I really enjoyed myself
talking to the people was a labor love
you know uh some of the agents were like
you have to charge for the for the book
signing and then charge for the book and
I'm like no I want to talk to him by
myself and I didn't get the [__] idea
that these people wanted stand up but
they did talk about the church a lot and
that's why we're [__] here you know
what I'm saying so thank you Lee for
agreeing to do this we're just gonna do
once a week we have no pressure here
right we have no pressure anymore we
don't give a [__] we just want to talk
to the people that love us we'll talk to
them and we're good to [__] go yeah
talk Tuesdays right we'll post on
Tuesday every Tuesday for right now
we're just going to start with one a
week and see how it goes you know Lee's
got a different schedule I got a
different [__] schedule so we'll take
it from there and without further Ado
Uncle Joey loves you tell them Lee you
love him I love you guys so excited to
be back and we will see you next Tuesday
Tip Top [__] Meo and now for a
word from our sponsor stay blessed
[Music]
it's Tuesday September the 5th this show
is brought to you by manscape don't lie
you probably been using manscape ball
shaver on your face that's okay I do it
too so now it's time to pick up the
beard hedger it's a cordless trimmer
that gives you 20 different hair cutting
lengths all with one guard no more messy
drawers full of extra add-ons listen I
used the beard hedger I trimmed my arm
pitch with it it's [__] tremendous
this baby has a long lasting battery and
a strong motor that will get you the
look that you want if you're a clean
shaving kind of guy the handyman is your
ticket to a smooth stubble free look
whether you got a five o'clock shadow or
you're working on a wizard beard
manscape has the tools for you right now
get 20% off and free shipping with code
Joey at manscape.com again 20% off and
free shipping at manscape.com use code
Joey hit hit the refresh button with
manscape